I do what I do because of my dad he'd  give his life through the pursuit of  knowledge  because up there is where our stories  can be told  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  this is a top-secret psychological  evaluation please describe your current  emotional state unsteady I'm ready to do  my job to the best of my abilities  [Music]  I will remain calm  [Music]  I will remain focused  [Music]  I look just like your dad there he was  the first man to the outer solar system  he was a pioneer but there was much more  to a man  [Music]  please state your mission objective I'm  attempting to stop an uncontrolled  antimatter iax that's threatened SCI  entire solar system we're approaching  Mars  [Music]  space con believes my father's  responsible  we're doing big things up here building  [Music]  what did he find out there in the abyss  the enemy up here is not a person or a  thing  it's the endless Boyd  the world awaits our discovery by sign  [Music]  [Music]